sie will die menschheit vernichten aber
das königreich saudi arabien hat der
roboter frau sofia die
staatsbürgerschaft verliehen damit ist
sie tatsächlich die erste maschine
weltweit mit bürgerrechten und pflichten
die aktion löst nicht nur diskussionen
unter frauenrechtlerinnen weltweit aus
sondern auch ki fachleute sind sich
nicht einig was davon zu halten ist ihr
habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünschte bekommt deswegen alle facts
zu roboter frau sofia und zwar jetzt
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen als ihr erfinder david tänzen
die roboter frau sofia fragt ob sie
menschen zerstören will guckt sie ihn
mit ausdruckslosen augen an
dann sagt sie ok ich werde menschen
zerstören
das war im märz 2016 und dieser bug soll
wohl mittlerweile behoben worden seien
naja wer weiß jetzt ist sophia meist
freundlich und komplett in die runde
schließlich ist sie seit ende 2017 ein
teil der menschheit saudi arabien hat
der kann also dieser künstlichen endlich
intelligenz die staatsbürgerschaft
verliehen bei twitter hieß es dazu es
ist oracle to be the first of the world
to recognize citizenship friedberg
com-news audi sofia
#fb 2010 teams und natürlich setzte
sofia als reaktion ihr happy face auf
einer ihrer 62 möglichen
gesichtsausdrücke sie sei stolz und
fühlte sich durch dieses historische
ereignis sehr geehrt die ki war
eigentlich zur konferenz eingeladen
worden um den fortschritt im bereich der
humanoiden ki künstliche intelligenz zu
demonstrieren und tatsächlich ihre
fähigkeiten menschliche ausdrucksweise
nach zu haben und sind erstaunlich in
einem interview kann man dann dennoch
einmal auf das große thema zurück der
moderator wollte von sophia wissen ob
maschinen zukünftig zu einer gefahr für
uns menschen werden könnten
sofias reaktion ein charmantes lächeln
er lese wohl zuviel allen masc und
schaue zu viele hollywoodfilme sofia
weiter solange du nett zu mir bist bin
ich ist auch zu dir roboter frau sofia
hatte ihre anerkennung als rechtsperson
im vorfeld tatsächlich selbst gefordert
irgendwann
der zukunft würde ich gerne in die
schule gehen unser neben hochziehen oder
vielleicht sogar ein haus kaufen und
eine familie gründen
diese doch eher menschlich angehauchten
träume könnte sich die ki nun also
theoretisch erfüllen sofia soll sich
jedenfalls besonnen haben sie soll jetzt
in der altenpflege eingesetzt werden und
will nach eigenen aussagen den menschen
helfen besser zu leben spannend auch
noch der augenblick als sophia gefragt
wurde ob sie als roboter ein bewusstsein
habe die antwort der ki
woher wissen sie denn dass sie ein
mensch sind im großen und ganzen steht
wohl marketing und pr hinter dieser
entscheidung der saudiarabischen
behörden und ja mit ihrem auftritt hat
sofia einen bleibenden eindruck
hinterlassen doch trotzdem die aktion
wirft viele fragen auf und die
resultierenden diskussionen sind mehr
als nur gesellschaftlich und politisch
angehaucht wir haben hier ja schon öfter
darüber berichtet sowohl stephen hawking
als auch ihren maske warnen vor den
gefahren die durch die entwicklung von
künstlicher intelligenz ki ausgehen
könnten anders dagegen der japanische
unternehmer masayoshi son der mit saudi
arabien eine mega city plant in der auch
roboter leben sollen seiner ansicht nach
seinem roboter zu klug um menschen
anzugreifen schließlich wüssten sie dass
es sinnlos sei
die europäische union jedenfalls denkt
schon länger über ein eigenes
rechtssystem für künstliche
intelligenzen und roboter nach
beispielsweise steht dem raum robotern
einen status als elektronische
persönlichkeit zuzuweisen
dies wäre im bereich schadenersatz
durchaus sinnvoll aber auch in anderen
bereichen des lebens kommen immer mehr
intelligente menschliche maschinen zum
einsatz und die frage der arbeitsgruppe
des eu parlaments bleibt wie können wir
verhindern dass die gesellschaft durch
roboter nicht entmenschlicht wird aber
nicht nur unter k expertinnen wird die
aktion heißt diskutiert auch das thema
frauenrechte in saudi arabien kam
dadurch nochmal auf die antenne denn
frauen sind dort männern noch längst
nicht gleichgestellt sie dürfen
beispielsweise nur verschleiert in die
öffentlichkeit sofia aber trat
unversteuert auf zudem müssen frauen in
saudi arabien einen männlichen
gesetzlichen vormund haben ohne den sie
das land
verlassen dürfen hallo absolut
unhaltbarer zustände und alles andere
als zivilisiert auch viele ausländische
arbeitskräfte haben in saudi arabien den
kritikern zufolge weniger rechte als
jetzt die roboter frau sofia ein
journalist schrieb dazu zitat ein
menschenähnlicher roboter hat die
saudische staatsbürgerschaft erhalten
werden millionen andere staaten bleiben
auf den punkt würde ich mal sagen wenn
ihr als erstes neues zum thema ki und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp mandant
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video von mir vorab garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt mit mir in der
redaktion von klicks und mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen oder andere
vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen und
hier gehts weiter sagt wir auch
draufklicken bedroht künstliche
intelligenz die menschheit da geht es
noch mal um diese grundsätzliche und
wichtige diskussionen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann